extreme drought conditions in northern
mexico
this reservoir in the outskirts of
monterrey is almost entirely dry
and many here worry the same will happen
to the local economy i worry over
another week of this things would only
worsen
boats are now stranded atop the dry lake
bed at la boca dam it's been months
since the region has seen any
significant rainfall experts have
identified several factors that are
contributing to the ongoing water crisis
here in northern mexico the most
significant of which is a weather
phenomenon known as la nina which
climate scientists say has been
exacerbated by climate change leading to
one of the worst droughts in the last 30
years
scientists say la nina has disrupted
regular weather patterns in northern
mexico this means that rains that were
supposed to begin in may still haven't
arrived and there's no telling when they
will
environmental activists say that despite
the drought bottling companies like
coca-cola heineken and others have
continued large-scale water extraction
making the situation even worse
we're living a great contradiction in
this city we owe a great deal to the big
companies but it's been at the cost of
the well-being of citizens and that's a
problem we need to completely rethink
the question of water usage
the water crisis in monterrey a city of
more than 5 million people has reached a
critical point
many now rely almost entirely on public
water tanks for some they are the only
source of water available
we have no water nothing comes out of
the top and we have to carry it back
home for cooking cleaning and even the
bathroom we buy our drinking water from
the supermarket
mexico's president has vowed to continue
to support efforts to supply water to
various cities in northern mexico
but experts say the strategy is not
sustainable adding that the only real
solution is rain
manuel rapalo al jazeera monterrey